Vincent van Gogh's art and life
captivated the world for more than 120
years every month there are over two and
a half million google searches for his
name now a team of movie makers has
turned that fascination into a first of
its kind film just released with the
help of more than 100 artists from
around the globe Jonathan Vigliotti has
the story one of cinema's most ambitious
new films was produced in a small studio
in Pollak here with the stroke of a
brush a team of painters brought to life
the work of Vincent van Gogh the final
result the first hand-painted film ever
made we have definitely without a doubt
invented the slowest form of filmmaking
ever devised in 120 years in the human
is the film's director we have the horse
and carton movie using letters written
by Van Gogh Welshman and his wife Dorota
cobiella tell the story of Van Gogh's
creative genius and sudden death Vincent
van Gogh was born in the Netherlands in
1853 over the course of his career he
painted over 800 canvases famous themes
including sunflowers and wheat fields at
37 years old after being released from a
mental institution he took his own life
without any explanation
under the man go from being absolutely
calm the suicidal in six weeks that
pivotal question is explored through
fictional interviews with the real-life
characters and locations depicted in 150
of Van Gogh's famous paintings
interesting man he was a genius
like a traditional film loving Vincent
began with a set and actors important
man like mr. t or van Gogh ask around he
filmed with live actors on green screen
we composited into the backgrounds of
those shots
van Gogh paintings we cut it together
like a live-action film but then we
projected each frame individually onto
canvas
as producer Ivan McTaggart explains a
total of 120 artists recruited from all
over the world turn those projections
into oil paintings
you're not just filling in or over
painting a scene as you see it you're
actually having to interpret a moving
scene in the style of an artist who died
126 years ago to be clear every single
frame of loving Vincent is painted by
hand all 64,000 of them the equivalent
of 64,000 canvases for second yeah it's
98 frames so he does a quarter or a
third of a second each day so something
like 20 days just for that one shot of
the car going through with the women the
entire 90 minute film took four years to
make and while there is computer
software that can create the illusion of
a painting with the click of a mouse
there's a nice quiet man Welshman says
computers could never replicate this
kind of authenticity loving Vincent is a
painstaking tribute to Van Gogh a moving
exhibit of his work unlike any before
for CBS this morning Saturday Jonathan
Vigliotti London every single train it's
it's hard to get a movie made generally
yep now to make this movie I mean that
is a Herculean effort and I love in this
computer graphics a whole drafting hats
off to you